موضوع عن جدليا في السودان وحول مكتبه
يزعم من اغلقها انها تفسد اخلاق الطلاب
وتضم مؤلفات ليست في مصلحه الطلاب لهذا
السبب اغلقت جامعه البحر الاحمر بالشرق
السوداني في حسب مدير عام المؤسسه ثقافيه
المسؤوله عنها الروائي مهند الدابي هو من
اعلن الخبر واسباب الاغلاق التي وصفها
بالواهيه مشيرا الى ان اداره الجامعه كانت
تترصد لاغلاق المكتبه كونها لا تتبع
لاداراتها ورغم هذا الجدل الذي اثره اغلاق
المكتبه بحثنا على صفحات الجامعه في مواقع
التواصل ولم نجد اي بيان او التعليق على
القراءه
[موسيقى]
مهند يعني المصدر اكاديمي بجامعه البحر
الاحمر هو طلب عدم الكشف عن هويته قال
بانه 70% من العوامل التي ادت لاغلاق
المكتبه هي عوامل داخليه ولا علاقه طلابها
بما يتم نشره الان من مساله كتب بتفسد
الاخلاق
طبعا حيث انني دائما ما كنت اجد همم
الترحيب والمؤازره من عمليه شؤون الطلاب
فمثلا دكتور ابو بكر بخيل عميد شؤون
الطلاب وقتها كان من اشد الداعمين لقيام
هذه المكتبه ومن نحن مكان كان مخصص لالعاب
البلياردو همم حيث عملنا على استصلاحه
وصيانته وتجهيزه بالطريقه التي ترونها
امامكم حيث دعمتنا الوكاله الامريكيه
للتنميه
في السودان في همم تحويل هذا المكان همم
من قاعه بلياردو الى مكتبه تحتوي على اكثر
من 1,000 كتاب واجهزه الكمبيوتر وتصوير
المستندات والتابعات والمكيفات الهواء
ومبردات الماء والاجلاس وغيره همم وكانوا
وجود المكتبه في هذه الجامعه وجودا طيبا
هادئا همم امنت الاداره الجامعيه بهذه
المكتبه وحطتها مكان لمده خمس سنوات عبر
عقد مواقع موثق ثم اتفاجانا خلال الثلاثه
اشهر الاخيره همم بان يتم اختيارنا بايقاف
العمل عبر مسئوله المكتبه في مدينه
بورسودان همم حيث اخترنا عميد عماده شؤون
المكتبات بانه اكتشف فجاه ان هناك مكتبه
داخل الجامعته لا تتبع له ثم تواصلنا مع
الدكتور الامين اوشيك مدير مكتب مدير
الجامعه ثم مكتب مدير الجامعه ثم الاخوه
في عماده شؤون الطلاب من اجل بحث حل هذه
المشكله
وللاسف لم نتوافق معهم في حل واصر هذا
الرجل همم على ان يتم اغلاق المكتبه ما
محدثا مديره المكتبه بان هذه الكتب ترسل
الاخلاق فاقترحنا عليه ان يتم ذكر
العناوين التي يرى بانها همم ليس من
الصالح ان توجد في هذه المكتبه لكنه لا
يعرف شيئا عن العناوين لم يسمي تلك
العناوين لم يتحدث عن العناوين عرضنا
عليها ان نسحب كل الكتب التي من شانها ان
تجعله قلقا او قد يراها غير صالحه لطلاب
بالغين عق في مرحله جامعيه لكن كل حاجه لم
يحدث للاسف
ذلك عندما نتحدث عن مكتبه جامعه الجامعيه
صوره مصغره من المجتمع اذا يحصل
مايعات يعني خليته للشارع ان تغلق جامعه
المكتبه بهذه الحجه هذا يعني اننا عد الى
مربع اكثر ظلاما من سنوات حكم الانقاذ حيث
كانت تضيق طوال 30 عاما في حكم الانقاذ هو
قد ادى همم بشكل مباشر الى اضعاف الانسان
في السودان المعرفيه والى خفض السقف
المعرفي للجميع وتحديدا شرق السودان يعني
همم جميع ولايات شرق السودان تعاني جدا
همم من تدني نسبه التعليم بها وانخفاض
مستوى الوعي فيها
تريد ان تعيد بالسودان الى الوراء
بكل تاكيد هذا ممكن جدا
[موسيقى]